i love this i love this i love
everything i love everything about
everything this is gonna be great so
great wait wait wait wait a minute wait
a
minute
keegan michael key is playing toad
but
but toad's not black
woke culture is ruining everything
hollywood in their damn virtue signaling
i know at least they cast seth rogen
properly oh yeah we'll give credit where
credit is due yeah yeah absolutely
[Music]
what's up reject nation we got
there's no controversy here maybe maybe
a little tiny one maybe depending on
your own feeling depending on your
opinion we are going to react to the
cast list here for the super mario
brothers
animated movie is this from illumination
yeah your minions peeps oh you know it's
going to be good and self-aware and
referential despicable mario oh i can't
wait it's me a chris pratt all i knew
was chris pratt right yeah this is who
you think of who are you thinking
mario all right so here's i'm gonna read
this right now and give our thoughts
john and i have not discussed this at
all off camera so here goes nothing
chris pratt as mario it's a me
chris pratt he's not gonna do it accent
is he that's the sad part about this i
could already tell he's not gonna do an
accent it's a me a mario so yeah we shot
this video i thought much the same thing
and then a couple hours later chris
pratt posted this that's not the voice
you'll have to wait to hear the voice
but we've been working hard at it and
and i'm really excited to announce that
i'm going to be the voice of that video
game that i dreamed about playing as a
kid dreams come true i hope he'd i
really want him to personally i feel
like it it sounds like you're doing your
seth rope i really i really wanted to do
the action i heard about seth rogen seth
rogen as donkey kong
and uh on to taylor joy's princess peach
has she done any other animated
properties i want to say she was a voice
in something but i couldn't name it
maybe it's like sing too but not any not
in any like you know huge way can we
google it or is that too much work
people don't want to watch us google
they want to watch us talk about whether
we should google nor do we want to do a
jump we just won't ever know we just
won't know guys but it can create
engagement if you guys know the answer
here that's right comment below but it's
nice to see another taylor joy cass in
here she funny enough she'd be a good
live-action princess speech
yeah i mean it's
i have so many thoughts about all of
this i feel like i mean on the outside
she is probably the most like yeah i
could see that casting because she is
slender and blonde
yes not exactly the actors i would have
imagined from prison speech a lot more
on point than some of these other people
charlie day as luigi well charlie day is
funny yes mario i'm trying to be
all right we gotta just
it's gonna be by the board with the you
know strings and stuff like that the
whole time except each string is just
gonna come out of a different warp tube
to bowser's castle jack black as bowser
okay yeah you could obviously see him
playing off that devilish charm really
accentuating all of that
so what's funny about this casting is
you can already hear how they're all
going not just because of the celebrity
association of them but just knowing
like okay yeah i get why you cast them
this is what they're probably gonna be
like keegan michael key is toad i really
like that pick i think these are all
really good voice over actors seth rogen
is donkey kong well i hope they let him
improvise fred harmison is cranky gog
okay and then we got other characters
here kevin michael richardson as comic i
don't know how to pronounce that i
actually don't know that character kamek
oh god why are we doing this video
sebastian maniscalo as spike
okay awesome that's good to hear chris
pratt i feel like that's an easy thing
to roll your eyes at the first time you
hear this right yes i did i think it's a
very easy thing to realize that just
because it's him he has that kind of
personality that i always like watching
him when he's there but there's
something about him that when i hear
he's doing one of these it's like oh god
but then i end up liking him anyway so
i'm like what am i even rolling my eyes
out i don't know i have the same general
reaction to him it's like you know going
into tomorrow war i was like oh here we
go and then i was like he's great
his voice work is awesome he's great in
both lego movies absolutely and he's
great and onward so i'm sure he'd do a
fine job here the thing about this is
this is not sounding like the super
mario movie we probably would have
imagined that nintendo would ultimately
approve yeah you know what i mean i
think it's going to be a lot of
self-awareness a lot of spoof qualities
and maybe that's what the super mario
brothers animated movie needs to be and
i'm sure it'll be funny and i'm sure
it'll be entertaining i just hope it's
not annoying that's the one quality i
wonder how much of this will have to
tend to super fans of the game how are
they going to try to make this appealing
all around it's probably going to have a
lot of hard fly going to be super
predictable peaches kidnap bowser yeah
yeah yeah i mean there are certain
aspects of mario that are classic that i
think will always pop up but i i just as
a viewer i feel like they would have a
pretty wide latitude to play around and
like do things that are inspired by the
mario worlds that gamers are probably
familiar with but maybe not necessarily
specifically those so that you could get
a new environment for everybody to be
holding you know you gotta throw some
mario kart in there well that's the
other thing you gotta do like the mario
party yeah
you gotta throw that all in there and
this is from the writer who did the
second lego movie okay so if you have
him in there you know obviously is very
meta and self-aware this could open up
the door for more nintendo-based stuff
you're already including donkey kong in
here yeah so you could get your own
donkey kong spin-off movie down the road
i think though here's
my concern about the future of this if
this pans out really well yes is that we
will not get the badass zelda movie that
we want i feel like they'll probably
turn it into a comedy because this is
obviously going to be a comedy and i
think super mario yeah uh lends itself
to being a comedy the thing though is
it's like okay i could see donkey kong
going that way i can see other nintendo
properties going down this path
but when you do zelda you better not
just make fun of it you know yeah that
has to be like a sweeping fantasy epic
of sorts even if it's not like heavy
like a lord of the rings i wouldn't want
it to be just like silly zelda because
those games don't have that spirit you
know even if they do have some humor
here or there i also i i don't know i'm
a little wary of this paving a road to
something where it's like we got the
nintendo server verse we're going to go
into nintendo land online where every
property exists in the
which is exactly what i can see
happening and i'm a little bit like i
just kind of want a mario movie to play
mario i have a strong impression that
they because this is not the same studio
the lego movie yeah so i have a very
strong impression that they got someone
from lego movie and they even have the
lead voice actor from lego movie because
they want this to be their lego movie
universe yeah and i mean in a lot of
ways that would make sense for all that
crossover to happen i just i don't know
i mean there's there's already a
wreck-it ralph and i don't want this to
become wrecking mario you know but at
the same time i mean it is a world with
a lot of room to breathe and have fun
because it is of a game so i i won't
just you know scrooge this
but like i said i'm sure the actual
viewing experience i'll be like yeah for
what the movie is it works i do
kind of feel though that
super mario doesn't need big cass like
this and i think they still could have
pulled off them thinking i don't know
what they're going for i still think
they could have pulled off a movie with
traditional voice over actors like over
the past couple years i've gotten to
know way more people in the voiceover
community and it really does suck just
how much they used to work especially
for these big animated films and now
it's all just given to celebrities and
i'm like well if you got some
professional voice over actors you
probably could have pulled off these
characters more in the voice of how we
know them from the games yeah but you're
not going to get that with this cast i
mean you might get it with some of them
because i look at people like kiki
michael key or even fred armisen and i'm
like those guys are all about doing
voices and characters and accents and so
i can michael key is going to be his
like fun manic stuff
yeah they're gonna get hollywood keegan
michael key to do that thing he does
when i'm like he's got so much in his
repertoire and and like yeah chris pratt
makes me wonder cause i'm like hey in
the animated films i've seen him and he
gives very affable and very charming
performances but they're all in his
general chris pratt voice and so i just
i i really hope that for this he might
at least be able to prove
why
he got the role instead of a more
seasoned voice actor it's the kind of
thing where you see this cast and you
know exactly what kind of movie it's
going to be
which uh could be
really entertaining it could be creative
and fun or it could really go downhill
but the question is to you guys what do
you think about the cast fun of the
super mario brothers movie yahoo
i'm donkey kong i am gonna throw a
barrel with you
where's my son subscribe click that bell
hit that like button leave your thoughts
down below we'll see you guys soon
[Music]